this is alabaster one of the most iconic
islands in one piece and this is cairo
the capital of egypt the ancient temple
of edfu the gambling city of las vegas
in the united states traditional
architecture from mali in west africa
the mechranga fort in india and even the
taj mahal the epic landmarks and
beautiful landscapes of four incredibly
different countries from all around the
world merged into one fantastic island
on the grand line with its own unique
history culture and people i just can't
stress enough how impressive i find this
alabasta is a desert kingdom located
halfway through the first part of the
grand line with a history dating back to
the infamous void century 900 years ago
at first glance the island seems to be
purely inspired by egypt with pyramids
and deserts but once i looked a little
closer it became clear that there is so
much more going on here brain diners the
large casino run by crocodile is a
condensed version of the luxor hotel in
vegas the main palace is inspired by
india's most famous landmark but the
roofs have been replaced with the golden
ones of the so-called dome of the rock a
very important islamic shrine located in
jerusalem this is fitting because
according to nicorobin it dates back
over 4
000 years
the capital city aruba to me seems to be
based on this ancient rocky fort in the
northwest of india that celebrates the
sacred spirit festival the tomb of kings
the oldest part of alabasta that
concealed the poneglyph is the spitting
image of the ancient temple of edfu that
is particularly famous for the advo
building texts that contain the history
of the ancient kingdom of egypt all the
way back to the quote-unquote early
prime evil age of the gods damn that's
cool i definitely want to go there
someday and how very fitting for a place
that contains part of the true history
of the one piece world and its gods
you also have characters like pell and
chaka that have zone fruits inspired by
the sacred animals of ancient egypt a
falcon and a chakal the king himself is
named cobra and the main antagonist is
crocodile an animal that lives in the
nile river which is ironic because he's
the one who took away all the country's
water supplies and yet what absolutely
blew my mind was that alabasta
officially is inspired by india which
i'm sorry but i found absolutely
ridiculous given all of this egyptian
influence and its name literally being a
pun on the words arab and the white
stone alabaster in japanese but anyways
what's up amanu and in case you're
wondering how i know all this there is
actually an official travel guide to the
one piece world that lists a lot of the
real-life inspirations for all the
fantastic places we visit that actually
only dropped back in 2021 and that i
haven't heard of for some reason until
now actually was doing research on this
topic myself when i just randomly
stumbled across it halfway through now i
guess if you clicked on this video
you're as fascinated by the world that
air or the author of one piece has
created as much as i am because building
a whole fictional world that feels alive
and real is actually one of the most
complex things you can do in
storytelling and since no one can create
a whole world out of nothing naturally
even if only subconsciously you will
adapt and incorporate some real world
elements into your imaginary world as
well using them as a base of inspiration
without of course copying things one to
one for me this has two big advantages
one it makes your world and your
characters feel familiar to the audience
and two it anchors your fiction in
reality to make it feel more believable
and relatable and i think oda sensei who
despite barely leaving his office is
obsessed with learning about the history
geography and culture of the world has
mastered this advanced technique to a
ridiculous level his world of islands
and pirates is incredibly unique and new
but still everything feels familiar and
coherent as i showed you with the
example of alabaster he achieves this by
taking a number of real-life
inspirations from all over the world and
then combines the attributes he likes
into something completely new
[Music]
so allow me to take you on a tour
through the one-piece world and all its
fantastic inspirations in no particular
order some of these are based on the
official book and others let's say
educated guesses and i want to start
with luffy's home dawn island in the
east
now most of these blue in general is
inspired by asian places nami's home is
inspired by indonesia zoro's village is
inspired by nada in japan and the
baratier is inspired by vietnam's
floating restaurants this makes sense
because it is literally called the east
blue asia being in the east and when i
looked deeper into this it actually
seemed to be the direction hola sensei
went with the entirety of the one piece
world the west blue for instance
features locations like o'hara that is
based on england's bollywood kingdom
that is yeah of course based on
hollywood and thriller bark that is
inspired by french gothic architecture
like the notre dame so anyways the goa
kingdom in the east blue also falls into
this pattern because it is based on the
philippines with all its jungles and
warm climates and by the way one of the
most beautiful countries i ever had the
pleasure to travel to the rich capital
and the great terminal seemed to be a
representation of smoky mountain a giant
landfill in manila the capital of the
philippines where people used to live
and work in heaps of garbage just like
in one piece the landfill experienced
devastating fires now in the story it's
the nobles that purposefully want to get
rid of all the poor people living there
to not anger the celestial dragons
coming to visits
the capital city itself however seems to
be based on the indian state of goa
india's richest region once again
contrasting the striking gap between
rich and poor now for fusha village on
the other hand it seems like oda sensei
drew inspiration from the english
countryside once again merging three
very different countries into one i wish
i could nerd out a bit more about how
awesome i found this combination but for
your sake let's move on this is the
freaky island of punk hazard that not
only looks like the world's largest
pokeball but is half mordor and half
north pole
now
you know basically how my balls felt
when i went into a japanese onsen in
winter can't recommend enough well you
might or might not be surprised when i
tell you that there is a place like this
in the real world as well because
iceland is pretty much a song of ice and
fire as well only that they were smart
enough to stop after four seasons
with some of the most unreal and epic
landscapes in the worlds here hot
glowing volcanic lava meets icy glaciers
with only a few inhabitants very similar
to how punk hazard's condition have made
it a hard place to live as well but damn
i really want to go to iceland so so
badly if you have any recommendations
let me know
[Music]
now lano the longest arc of the entire
story is of course inspired by japan
however there are so
ridiculously many details from real
japan hidden throughout this arc there
would probably be an entire video of its
own so let me know if you want to see
that next we have a place that i have
enjoyed talking about a lot in my videos
recently drum island home of chopper
[Music]
[Applause]
this island as a hole that is always
covered in snow is mostly based on
northern america and the rocky mountain
region the iconic cone-shaped peaks are
most likely inspired by the devil's
tower in the north of wyoming and yeah i
know i can't believe that's a real place
either the town of cocoa await is
basically an exact copy of the canadian
city banff however interestingly enough
bighorn the town where the straw hats
actually arrive appears to be inspired
by the cute city of alberobello in itae
i wanted to say italia but it's yeah
italy got lost in that italian accent a
little bit too much right now meanwhile
and as a german i can't believe i missed
this drum castle where dr kureha resides
is of course based on the legendary
neuschwanstein castle in the state of
bavaria where i'm actually from
embarrassing oda sensei really went out
of his way to create a winter wonderland
here giving it that christmasy special
vibe before i go on to the next big one
here are a few smaller ones whiskey peak
is inspired by taos in new mexico twin
peaks is basically thatcher islands also
in the us actually just talked about
that recently in a theory about the one
piece being inside a whale like laboot
the castle on top of the red line
marijua from where the government rules
the world is inspired by the and i'm
really sorry for slaughtering this
chateau de chamber
in france as you might have guessed a
two-hour car ride away from paris
[Music]
both the real chateau and marijua have
vast gardens and are just a pure
statement of power and luxury now
interestingly enough it is really
closely connected to the french
revolution where the revolutionary army
took it away from the governing nobility
i wonder if that might become relevant
in the story at some point though the
giant elephant is most likely a twist on
the whale with an island on its back
trope but i believe that oda sensei
might have seen an image of this very
famous rock that looks just like an
elephant off the coast of iceland
the city of the minks on the other hand
is inspired by the monument valley in
yemen there's also this island called
the romel kingdom that we see in
cavendish flashback his alter-ego hakuba
is based on the infamous serial killer
jack the ripper and his hometown in
general is based on 19th century london
as you can clearly see and i personally
am inspired by you subscribing to the
channel if you want more one piece
content like this is amazon lilly an
empire only run by the women of the cuja
clan located in the com belt where luffy
was transported by kumar
now while the women themselves are
clearly inspired by the legendary amazon
warriors from greek mythology the island
itself is actually inspired by the
so-called hanging temple in the
northeast of china close to the
mountains of mongolia yeah i know these
look absolutely unreal towering over 30
meters from the ground inside that cliff
but they are an actual place built over
1
500 years ago and i really love how
unique this combination of these two
ideas is making amazon lily a truly
spectacular place
then we have dressrosa you might already
know that this island is heavily
inspired by spain and spanish culture
for example with viola's tango dance the
architecture resembles that of the
famous gaudi whose influence you can see
all over barcelona park gill in
particular looks a lot like the
buildings we see throughout the country
under doflamingo's rule and just how
crocodile was inspired by an animal that
is connected to egypt don quijoto
flamingo himself is a nod to both the
flamingos living in the spanish salinas
but also to the dance flamenco oh and of
course to the famous story of don
quixote himself oda sensei actually
commented the following here himself
this is my older voice when i took a
close look at doflamingo and tried to
think of what country would suit him i
arrived at the conclusion that it must
be spain i have already previously
mentioned that the countries of one
piece are all inspired by real life
countries in another sbs but it's the
first time i actually got feedback from
the residents of such a country now i
sometimes can be irresponsible in the
way i draw and so if you do see anything
that seems like a half-baked version of
your culture or buildings please forgive
me remember it's just a manga i i wish
more people would actually take the last
sentence to hearts the giant colosseum
on the other hand is of course inspired
by the actual colosseum in rome or there
are actually some in ancient greece as
well now let's move on to my absolute
favorite location in all of one piece
water seven and not only because anislav
and water seven are my favorite arc but
also because the island itself is just
absolutely breathtaking
[Music]
it's a floating city with canals instead
of streets that is famous for its
shipwrights this city is of course
heavily inspired by venice that is also
built on water and full with canals the
venetians were also famous for their
ships that they used to build a
flourishing global trading empire
reflected in water 7 skill with
shipbuilding as well now if you ever
have the chance to actually visit this
place it's just as breathtaking as it
looks maybe even a bit more so the masks
of the venetian carnival are used
incredibly creatively to introduce the
cipher pull agencies
the building of the galela company that
is run by frankie's stepbrother iceberg
is inspired by the piazza de la
anfiteatro in the tuscany in northern
italy the only thing that seems to be
non-italian on water 7 is its clear
resemblance to the island monson i'm
just slaughtering that again monsta
mikael monsan michael
mikhail in the normandy in france that
depending on the tides is completely
surrounded by water as well and strongly
resembles the shape of water 7. but
let's go back to venice for a second not
only is the city slowly sinking into the
ocean every single year but it
frequently experiences the so-called
aqua alta a phenomenon where the city is
completely flooded by high tides and so
i suspect that this is the actual
inspiration for the enormous aqua laguna
a tsunami-like wave that rolls over
water 7 every single year and causes the
island to sink a little bit into the
ocean
and honestly i can't help but wonder
what secrets lie beneath the surface
here as well as you know i'm convinced
that there is a much bigger and deeper
secret to this stunning world of one
piece and why so much of it is
underwater for example the connection
between the aqua laguna and the giant
hull under in this lobby and what do
devil fruits have to do with all of this
one crazy but very real possibility for
example is that the devil fruits
actually originate from a giant tree on
love tale that is under the sea just
next to water 7. and that's why you
really shouldn't ignore this video right
here because it will prove to you that
one piece's world building goes way
deeper than you could ever dream